you know it's funny it's almost like we
played a record and then we stopped and
then we started playing a record
backwards I'll change because who was
like uh we think it's now acceptable for
16 year olds oh we think it's now
acceptable for 12 year olds actually we
think that uh to the states that will
mandate it if their Governors are smart
we can go to 10 year olds remember that
we kept going down uh we think
eight-year-olds would be fine we kept
going down now the who said no I don't
think any of the 8 10 12 16s or 18s it's
like we're going backwards they they
don't need it remember that we went down
the ages now we go back up the ages
there's no legitimacy here